uh you got your own holiday in Fon
County yep turbo day yep that's got to
be [__] sweet man it's incredible
like what happens that like what like we
see that happening but like what what
comes with that anything cool I mean
we're organizing right now um the turbo
Day July 8th it's just really like a a
opportunity for me to just just do stuff
for like the kids and the community so
you kind of turn that into opportunity
to help the community out yeah you know
what I mean give it give it a actual
time and place instead of it you know me
coming for Memorial Day or something
like that and trying to do something or
compete so or Thanksgiving or yeah you
know Turkey driving all that stuff I did
turkey drives this year too but with
your own day is like it came about I was
trying to do something for the community
but you needed like permits and all of
this stuff to to take over like the
parks and stuff down there you can't
just do it and um I got to work with the
city and we just couldn't knock it out
last year and they gave me a day just
for even trying and trying to really
like make it happen cuz nobody does
anything on that side and that'll just
be easier to just do it this year you
know I already know who the right people
to call and how to organize everything
so it's it's for me it's just a way to
show the kids this is something this is
this is what you do once you get to this
place and Inspire these kids cuz it was
nobody that was doing that when I was
young what is uh for people who are
watching this maybe some kids who are
watching this who are trying to figure
out the production game what is your
layout are you using Pro Tools are you
using Fruity Loops like what is your
production interface your go-to that's
some exclusive [__] but I'm I'm going
tell you you know what I mean but um I
use a a a number of things so it could
be a little bit of Ableton for my
Melodies and into FL and I mix it in
Protools or I I reverse it and you know
if we going through the through the
keyboards I'm recording in Protools and
taking it to to FL and cleaning it up in
Ableton but that's like usually my main
three those three yo it's crazy like I
feel like more hip-hop producers should
use Ableton cuz I feel like they don't
yeah cuz Ableton like it's hard to use
it it's very intimidating when you open
it yeah yeah that's the word for sure
but like I feel like cuz I've like I got
a homie of mine who uses Ableton and
he'll show me things you can do in
Ableton and I'm like why isn't everybody
using this [__] is crazy this [__]
difficult to use BR no but it looks
crazy yeah cuz it looks different than
like Fruity Loops or Protools it's like
its own thing and then they got that
ablon touch with all the [__] buttons
and [__] yeah yeah yeah it's difficult
it's difficult but it's hard though
where do you like do you are you like
actively looking for packs in terms of
your sounds and [__] or are you like
having people send you packs are you
getting Loops are you doing like your
own Loops like give me some what you say
packs like what do you mean like like
you got to like your like where you
getting your drums are you find your own
drums are you are you grab oh uh yeah
kind of like if if it's like a certain
time and I need a certain thing I'll
tweet it out and then like all the guys
that send me
something yeah and I go through them but
I I got a programmer in Atlanta and he
just keep me up to date with all the
newest newest [__] what about on the
loop side cuz that is an entry point for
a lot of up and cominging producers I'm
stepping away from Loops I'm doing my
own Melodies okay it's like the the loop
game is just became
a [__] it's not the loop game anymore
you know what I mean it's like a it's
like a different place and I feel like
it's it's no originality in it yeah for
people who don't know cuz some producer
geek talk like uh if you're an upand
cominging producer you might send out
hey I'm looking for some Loops yeah
right and so that might be your way in
if you got some fire samples or Loops
that could be your way in getting your
first placement and but then you got
like you said the loop shit's getting
so uh washed washed down cuz it's cuz
there all these free loops what's the
website called with all the [__]
packs and splice and there's all this
[__] so it's like I always compare it to
like DJing and Sado like when Sado came
yeah like it made DJing so much easier
right you didn't need to have these
turntables these records and I feel like
splice is like that with producers cuz
like you really don't need to know how
to make a beat all you really got to do
is just line up bars and like you could
go on splice and if you're at least like
semi competent on Protools you can make
you can get you can get it down you can
make a beat for sure so it's like I just
noticed that like just so much more I'm
like you know we had an artist we were
working with and this kid never made a
beat before and he downloaded a bunch of
[__] on splice and he played a beat and
I was like hey yo who did this he's like
I just did it and I was like you just
did it he's like this the first beat I
ever made talking about Jake I was like
this [__] is what's happening like how
is this possible like cuz you know when
I was a kid we had the Funk Master Flex
video game on a PlayStation 2 O MTV
gener MTV generate on a first
PlayStation you make beats on the
PlayStation what is that it was fire
heard of that yeah so there was this MTV
beat making video game on the first
PlayStation and then there was a funk
Flex beat making game on the PS2 that
was
fire like you could like program beats
on this [__] game there was like
actual like some producers who would
like actually like run the PlayStation
into like Pro Tools and take the beats
out of it I never heard of that bro
super fire you should check it out